Vanya and kuzmitch are shooting a new
music video in their village of Nanaia
charm oda near Parham in the Urals this
time they've decided to cover a small
see Russian song Ullaeus terekhova and
Mika echos Minnick don't want to impart
a message about the deeper meaning of
life it's supposed to be fun we've had
lots of fun already
Mikhail's grandfather also lives in the
village his house is a prop closet
studio and stage rolled into one this is
where the duo recorded their summer hit
a cover of Canadian singer kaisers
hideaway when young and Kuzmich
transposed the setting of kaisers hit
from urban New York to the Russian
provinces their version went viral on
the Internet
and they became famous overnight
completely by surprise though they've
got some practice behind them they've
always parodied songs on the radio
ever since they joined a theater group
ten years ago when they were students
but what a G he be when it's not going
to keep you on for it to be a whenever a
hit is played over and over again the
song stays with you the whole day but it
doesn't just go round and round in your
head and then voila we had to work
really hard on our appearances our roles
our performances their next video
features even more demanding dance
routines
they have a feeling their unique charm
will shine through and they're making a
statement about the sanctions dispute
between Russia and the West we go and
see granddad and we take pleasure in
village get yourself a house here not
abroad harvest your apples and onions
and you don't have to worry about
sanctions at all
of course Yulia and mica all know that
Moscow and international politics are a
long way away for the inhabitants of
nice nature Moda here the villagers seem
more interested in their young stars
because grandad is their biggest fan
it's really great what they've managed
to do it's turned out well and
everybody's interested in of them and
that they're filming here our village is
becoming famous it might become even
more famous if Vanya and Koos mitches
new video also goes viral